cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent there he is john
dickerson hello john dickerson was up
late last night
so thank you john for getting up early
with us i know you're up covering the
convention last night i was watching you
guys
let's be with you we're always glad when
you're here let's talk
let's start with michelle obama because
it seems like she certainly has set a
very high bar when it comes to
energizing the party
you know they didn't call her the closer
for nothing back in the day she was
she she started out at some point in the
speech where she said i hate politics
and then proceeded to give a very
political speech which is out of
character for her in terms of
tone content and the delivery a lot of
people i was looking at it last night i
heard it described as elegant shade
what did you make of it well as i
understand how shade works
you have to be a little less direct than
she was i mean this
this wasn't so much shade as it was
actually it felt like to me a huge uh
spotlight right on what she says is the
problem which
in her uh very clear and direct words is
the incumbent president
they have to do three things at this
convention and she did all three one
is energize the base she basically said
get out and vote
immediately democrats are very worried
in this covet election that um
that they're going to have trouble
voting and getting out the vote that's
always a challenge for democrats that
will be more of one in this race the
second thing is to find the turf of what
this election is about
they want it to be about character and
the response to both covet 19
and the racial discussion we're having
in america
and david axelrod used an expression
that i think was useful which is
that character has a cost in other words
it's not some abstraction
michelle obama made the case that donald
trump's lack of empathy and character
has a cost in terms of american lives
and then the final thing is testimony
and witness about joe biden
which she did in talking about what she
knows in the personal joe biden
that's what they're trying to do all
week and she did all three of those
things
yeah it seems that even the republicans
were saying that michelle obama
knocked it out of the park last night
but what do you make of this virtual
convention
do you think it delivered i think it's
so hard to have these kind of
events with no audience when you're so
propelled by the audience applause
you know when we talk about this people
think why are we so obsessed with the
way it looks and the theatrics of this
well because what conventions do at
least in the modern age is use the
theatrics
as a kind of freight train on which they
put the message and that's to energize
the the base it's also to speak to
undecided voters and also try to put the
opposition in a box
so how it comes across matters and i
think that there are obviously they were
wrestling with that what we will see is
whether a speech like michelle obama's
which was clearly the highlight of the
night gets passed around in social media
and on youtube and the rest of it and if
that's the case then it does what a
traditional convention tries to do
there are all kinds of internal things
they're trying to do too you know
bernie sanders speech was a message of
unity for his supporters kind of narrow
casting there
handing the microphone over to regular
people was a nice touch in terms of
trying to
speak to that unity message so there
were some some
nice attempts to do what you would
normally do in a convention
but i think the real question is how
does it live on
afterwards in the social media world
to see if it really has any effect
that's long lasting
in past conventions it seems that they
would highlight rising stars
in this particular convention when you
look up the lineup they're going back to
a lot of the
i don't want to say older leaders but
past leaders do you think that that's an
intentional well it's partially because
they don't they're they have limited
time
um and um uh will i think it's it is
intentional but also you know part of it
is gail there's not um
what happens when those rising stars
come on is is sometimes not everybody's
looking
and then suddenly uh everybody notices
the reaction that's happening in the
room
and then they become a rising star um
i'm not sure that everybody knew that
barack obama in 2004 was going to
um light up the arena the way he did it
was only until the arena lit up
that it kind of gained a certain
momentum so um
one of the challenges this year is it's
hard to have a rising star who gives a
speech
in this constrained format yeah very
good point yeah hey
hey john i got a question here i want to
jump in on on unity
every candidate has to pull together the
different wings of the party but the
wings in this case in this year are
pretty far apart and we saw that with
a democratic socialist bernie sanders on
one side but then you also have a
republican governor
in a democratic convention in the form
of john kasich what is that gap signal
to you
yeah you know usually they're trying to
build unity and they're just grabbing
duct tape and and just
papering it all together for the moment
and hoping it sticks
what struck me about bernie sanders
speech um
this time um was that it was a
full-throated endorsement of joe biden
set the stakes for his own supporters
who uh might not like
uh joe biden but it's made the case for
him and said basically the stakes are
too high for you to
to sit out and that was in stark
contrast to his 2016
speech where you could almost hear the
grinding of his teeth as he was
making the case for hillary clinton um
which overstates it a little bit but it
was nothing close to this
in terms of the the disparity the
disparate nature of the the unity
message that they were sending i think
it's
one of the things that the democrats
want to emphasize is the idea that joe
biden represents a kind of old-timey
unity
which means reaching out to the other
party which means
representing or at least listening to
diverse viewpoints and part of what
they're trying to do is build an
appetite for something that hasn't been
on the menu for a while
which is this idea of unity i don't
think it's going to be
a huge lasting impact but it it it is
part of
what they're trying to do which is
define the turf they want this election
to be
on their argument is donald trump has
done everything to keep the country
unified and they wanted to have a kind
of tableau of unity
and in that case having everybody from
john kasich to bernie sanders
suggests that that kind of broad unity
all right john dickerson
as always good to see you my dentist dr
messiah says it's not good to grind your
teeth
so they need to stop doing that thank
you thank you john dickerson thank you
bye